total faszinierend herumzulaufen den
atmosphäre mit auch zu schnappen und
interessieren vielen jungen leute hier
irgendwie auch so leiden also liebes
publikum liebe gäste im saal und
anderswo herzlich willkommen zur don't
kill the messenger
[Musik]
wenn niemand
als berater für eine bundesregierung
arbeitet mit der begründung er
interessiert sich für das thema und
disqualifiziert einen dafür finde ich es
richtig schwach ehrlich gesagt also ist
irgendwie so nichts halbes und nichts
ganzes und da sie auf der gamescom ist
das noch eine provokation meistens ganz
gut weil man sich dann selber mal
eindruck macht und nicht nur büro sind
solche sachen entscheidet und vorschlägt
und selber bei guckt und vielleicht
gespräche pro person weil ich jetzt
nicht so aber wie jeder sein
rein rechtlich ist das was wir gemacht
haben eigentlich lächerlich
das hat der ogh im grunde so entwickelt
aufgrund einer e commerce richtlinie und
wir haben uns nur diesen einen punkt
herausgegriffen und eben gesagt oder
definiert was ist eine aktive plattform
und das ist das worum es eigentlich geht
und da draußen brannte dieses völlig
explodierte und emotionale gegeneinander
oft auf den seiten was der sache
natürlich am ende nicht gut tut
verdient hatten
die 1
jüngere menschen respektieren
ich meine er plötzlich mit drei jahren
also wirklich nicht geben
wie kann ich bin eher ein fan von face
to face als dann immer mit dem finger
irgendwohin zu zeigen
mal schauen ob es funktioniert dass er
sich das alles mal so ein bisschen
angucken kann ist ja schon mal gutes
[Musik]
in stadionatmosphäre
also diese wettkämpfe die dann
stattfinden
es ist irgendwie fassen
dass manche 300 euro
ausgeben um anderen beim spiel zu kommen
denn ich habe etwas mit dem netz place
ja mein tag gestartet
doch dazu müssen die männer
das macht das buch jemanden so der
simulierten kann aber gar nicht
eingesetzt
also ich das
ja ist es für mich so ein bisschen meine
kinder
jetzt wollt ihr ein bild machen sich
jetzt nicht
die passionierte es hätte ich mich
selber nicht ob in dem alter gar nicht
so interessiert die wissen
aber auch verantwortung
für ihn beginnt ich finde das total sa
entwickelt
nein also im moment laufen
ich weiß dass ich hier irgendwie diese
diese figuren hier muss man irgendwie
mit anderen zusammen
also was ich habe manchmal sorgen
das
der welt
verschwindet in der heimat virtuell
also bei dem
ich meine wir versuchen hat politiker
betonen dass straße ländern
insofern
da passen die virtuelle bewusst machen
kann
da habe ich dann
natürlich überspringt dass man das auch
jetzt selber
das nicht so
wir haben klargemacht